estamos en el problema número 12 y creo
que debería de hacer una pausa porque me
muero de hambre pero tengo que resistir
aunque ojo tú no debes de matarte de
hambre
eso no está nada bien porque es muy
importante que alimentas tu cerebro
comiendo bien y además qué alimento es
tu cerebro con problemas de ese arte
como este el problema número 12 así que
dibujemos un plano cartesiano dibujemos
un plano cartesiano y bueno este es el
eje de las 10 ok y este es el eje de las
íes más creo que aunque muero de hambre
saldré un poco hacer algo de ejercicio y
tal vez a correr un poco o qué sé yo
pero recuerda que tú no debes de hacerlo
pues seguramente estás creciendo y es
muy importante que te alimentes bien y
bueno también es muy importante que
hagas ejercicio este es el eje de asx
este es el eje de las yes bueno yo tuve
la suerte por ejemplo de estabilizar un
crecimiento de 10 d ya no crecer más en
el metro con 75 cm
metros pero bueno regresemos a este
problema tengo aquí un rectángulo un
rectángulo que espero que sea un
rectángulo que no tenga hambre perfecto
tengo un rectángulo por aquí y este
rectángulo
tiene la cualidad de que por aquí va a
pasar una figura que se parece mucho a
una parábola así que vamos a intentar
dibujarlo ya tengo esta herramienta
seleccionada y ahora si se dibujó una
parábola por aquí se dibuja del otro
lado pero esta no me gustó tengo una
palabra parecida a esta es una parábola
que pasa por este punto perfecto esta sí
me gustó ok
tengo esta parábola y esta parábola pasa
por este rectángulo que tiene nombre
este punto de aquí donde se intercepta
la parábola con este rectángulo se llama
un este punto de aquí se llama r este
punto de acá se llama p y este punto de
acá se llama ese y además me dicen que
aquí está el 1 en x aquí está el 1 en x
está en menos 1 en x en menos 1 en x
perfecto vamos a ver qué me dice el
problema si p
ese es un rectángulo y esta función que
tengo aquí es la función que es igual a
x cuadrada déjame ponerlo con este color
esta función de aquí es igual a x x
cuadrada aa por x cuadrada es decir es
una parábola vamos bien en esta idea ok
donde hay una constante a es constante
constante ok y además el perímetro del
rectángulo prs el perímetro de este
rectángulo son 10 unidades cuánto vale
de hecho lo que me preguntan es saber el
valor de amd ok y bueno para sacar el
valor de amd pues es muy importante el
dato que me dan me dicen que el
perímetro de este rectángulo en verde su
perímetro son 10 unidades pero vamos a
ver qué podemos saber este rectángulo en
verde fíjate bien sigue aquí estoy en el
y no muevo para acá llegó al 1 en x por
lo tanto la distancia que hay de que acá
es una unidad ok y de aquí para acá pues
también hay una unidad porque llego al
menos 1 en x y del -1 al 0 en distancia
hay una unidad también creo que de hecho
ya vemos que un problema muy parecido
este en algún momento y bueno si de
hecho este mide una unidad y este mide
una unidad de entonces en total mide 2
unidades déjame ponerlo la distancia que
hay aquí hasta acá son dos unidades ok y
si ésta mide dos unidades como es un
rectángulo ésta también mide dos
unidades ahora supongamos que este esta
altura mide a no sabemos cuánto mide así
que pongámosle h esta altura mide h y
esta de aquí también mide a perfecto
entonces cómo sacamos el perímetro de
este rectángulo bueno pues el perímetro
de este rectángulo y lo voy a cambiar de
color el perímetro
no de hecho me gusta otro color que no
hemos utilizado muy utilizar este de
aquí el perímetro es igual a 2 más 2 más
h más h
dos más h más h o dicho de otra manera
el perímetro de este rectángulo en verde
tienes pues es cuatro más dos veces h ok
esto es lo que sabemos el perímetro de
este rectángulo pero además sabemos que
vale diez unidades nos dice el problema
es que vale diez unidades de hecho es
este dato que tengo aquí y si el
perímetro vale diez unidades
creo que ya podemos despejar de aquí a h
voy a obtener que dos veces h
es lo mismo que 10 menos 4 lo cual es 6
ok h es lo mismo que 6 entre 2 lo cual
es 3 h balde 3 es decir que la distancia
que hay aquí acá son 3 unidades y por lo
tanto la distancia que ella que aqap
también son 3 unidades
guau creo que esto nos va a dar pie a
que ya podamos escribir los puntos
importantes aquí hay dos puntos
importantes y quiero que te descuentan
los puntos más importantes es este punto
de aquí y este punto de aquí porque son
los puntos en donde se intersecta mil
parábola con
este rectángulo que tengo aquí ahora
creo que ya sabemos cuál es el valor de
este punto de aquí bueno pues vamos a
ver caminamos 1 en x por lo tanto tiene
coordenadas 1 coma
subimos tres unidades en y por lo tanto
justo aquí estamos parados en el valor
de tres en james es decir que este punto
tiene como coordenadas 1,3 y de hecho
también podremos saber el valor de este
punto de aquí este punto de aquí tiene
como coordenadas menos 1 en x nos
movimos una unidad hacia la izquierda
después del origen por lo tanto va a ser
menos 1 en x y tiene también una altura
de 3 es decir es el punto menos 13 ok y
porque serán importantes esos puntos
bueno porque estos puntos como estar en
la parábola y están en el rectángulo los
podemos sustituir aquí ya está ya casi
tenemos la solución de este problema
atrás lo que vamos es el valor de amd
ahora sí nosotros sabemos uno de estos
puntos de esta parábola porque no lo
sustituimos aquí y encontramos el valor
de amd que estamos buscando es más
déjeme cambiar el color de a
dice quién es igual a a por x cuadrado
hasta aquí vamos bien pero yo sé este
punto de aquí que cuando x vale 1 le
vale 3 cuando x vale 1 lleva al de 3 y
por lo tanto puedo decir que 3 es igual
a a por 1 elevado al cuadrado este punto
recuerda que está en la parábola bien el
rectángulo eso es lo más importante y
bueno de aquí puedo tener que a valer 31
cuadrados 1 por aesa es igual a 3 y es
justo lo que yo quería así que ya está
nosotros ponemos abajo la respuesta de
que avale 3 y ya tenemos la solución de
este problema está de lujo así que bueno
un problema creo que no estaba tan
difícil vamos a resolver el siguiente
problema adiós el problema número 12 y
bienvenido el problema número 13
el problema número 13 que dice lo
siguiente si a volver más ven esto es
igual a a más 12
y nos dicen que en este caso vale
vale 2
vale 3 cuánto vale
de hecho esto es una incógnita ok pues
se me ocurre que hay dos formas de
resolverlo pero que una es muy sencilla
vamos a ponerle por acá la primera forma
que se me ocurre de resolver esto es
decir vamos a sustituir tanto amd como
hace es decir que si a vale 2 me
quedaría 2 b más b
esto es igual a a más 12 es decir a dos
más dos porsche pero se vale tres más
dos por tres o de otra manera
3 b es lo mismo que dos más 6 3 b es lo
mismo que 8 y b&b es 8 tercios que es
justo lo que yo quería perfecto el valor
de bp es ocho tercios ahora también
quiero que te des cuenta que hay otra
forma de resolver este mismo problema y
se me ocurre que tal vez desde un
principio tú pudiste ver qué se podía
factorizar laver es decir de esta
expresión que tengo aquí
decir que es exactamente lo mismo que
poner ven que multiplica quien bueno en
primer lugar multiplica a am y después
multiplica a 1 porque aquí tenemos
solamente una vez por lo tanto está
multiplicando a uno más uno ve que
multiplica a más uno es lo mismo que a
más 12 y de aquí podemos despejar el
valor de 20 es decir que b b es igual a
más 12 y está que está multiplicando a
ver déjame ponerlo con otro color esto
que está multiplicando a b lo voy a
pasar
dividiendo entonces entre a más 1
a más 2 cm o esperas pérez pero aquí me
faltó una serie ambas 12 entre a más 1
ahora yo sé que avale 2 que se vale 3
pues vamos a sustituir y que me va a
quedar que ven es igual a am
pero a vale 22 más dos por ser pero se
vale tres entre dos más uno dos más uno
o dicho otra manera esto es lo mismo que
dos por tres y seis más dos son 88 entre
38 tercios y llegamos a la misma
respuesta dos métodos para resolver el
mismo problema llegamos a la misma
respuesta por lo tanto podemos super
asegurar que estamos bien recuerda que
el e7 es un examen contratiempo pero
bueno el problema número 13 vamos al
problema número 14 el problema número 14
igual tiene un montón de líneas que
dibujar y todo esto por ustedes
muchachos y creo que la satisfacción de
hacer manualmente todos estos ejercicios
que ustedes saquen un puntaje alto en
los vídeos de ls atm y en su examen del
s
un puntaje perfecto así que a darle
muchachos déjame tomar esta herramienta
y vamos a ponerlo tengo dos rectas por
aquí una línea parecida a ésta ok
y después tengo otra recta parecida
está
es algo más o menos como por aquí
ok más o menos
algo así ok me quedo creo que bastante
bien el dibujo y vamos a poner los datos
que me dan me dicen que esta recta de
color salmón de salmón sin hijos tiene
el nombre de acá estaba le cam esta
amarilla la que se entromete tiene el
nombre de l o no espera espera que estoy
haciendo perdóname tiene el nombre de l
mientras que estas dos tienen el nombre
de m esta se llama m y esta se llama n
ok y además me dan dos ángulos y tres
puntos este ángulo déjame cambia de
color este ángulo se llama 10 grados y
este ángulo se llama x x grados ok
perfecto y además me dan tres puntos me
dan que este punto se llama a este punto
se llama a este de aquí este se llama b
y este por acá se llama c
y bueno que me dice el problema en la
figura siguiente m es paralela a en
estas dos rectas son paralelas paralelas
ok vamos bien y el be seca al ángulo a
veces viste acá que significa eso bueno
cuando tenemos que una línea biseca al
ángulo
abc lo que quiere decir es que lo está
partiendo justo a la mitad es decir que
la medida de este ángulo se va a dividir
justo en dos por la recta l o dicho de
otra manera cuando el fbi seca al ángulo
abc lo que quiere decir es que está
dividiéndolo en dos ángulos iguales es
decir que este ángulo y este ángulo
tienen la misma medida valen lo mismo
porque l los corta justo a la mitad
perfecto y además me dicen si ya está
entre 45 y 55 grados 45 grados es menor
que ya que a su vez es menor que 55
perfecto lo que me preguntan es cuál es
un posible valor para x para x atrás lo
que vamos es x
bueno pues
se me ocurre que en una primera forma de
resolver este problema sería dándole un
valor ayer supongamos que vale
necesitamos un ángulo de 45 grados y 55
grados pues creo que 50 grados me parece
una buena opción vamos a suponer que
lleva los 50 grados 50 grados ok si
lleva de 50 grados este ángulo de aquí
entonces que me pueden decir de este
ángulo de aquí todo este ángulo entero
este ángulo de aquí cuánto vale bueno
pues si lleva de 50 grados
estos dos ángulos son correspondientes
son ángulos correspondientes porque
tenemos una recta que cruza a dos rectas
paralelas y cuando tenemos dos rectas
paralelas y una recta que las cruzan
este ángulo siempre es exactamente el
mismo que este ángulo por lo tanto todo
este ángulo de aquí hasta acá vale 50
grados 50 grados ahora si la recta l
biseca al ángulo
abc eso quiere decir que este ángulo y
este ángulo son iguales y son la mitad
ángulo de aquí la mitad de 50 grados por
lo tanto este ángulo debe de valer 25
grados y este también debe de valer 25
grados ambos deben de valer 25 grados si
yo me fijo en este ángulo en este de
aquí ok
déjame ponerlo con un color más
estridente para que tú lo veas perfecto
con este de aquí este ángulo es
exactamente igual que este ángulo estás
de acuerdo
tenemos una recta y otra recta queda
cruzada y por lo tanto estos dos ángulos
son iguales pero además estos dos
ángulos cumplen que son iguales a éste
este porque viene de la misma recta ya
este de aquí es decir estos dos ángulos
son iguales porque son ángulos opuestos
y si este vale 25 grados pues éste
también vale 25 grados y su opuesto
también vale 25 grados es decir que x un
posible valor para x son 25 grados esta
podría ser una de tu solución ahora esto
en el dado caso de que valiera 50 grados
pero ya puede valer cualquier valor
entre
5 grados 55 grados ahora date cuenta que
cualquier valor que tome aquí james es
el mismo valor que va a tomar este
ángulo y se va a dividir entre 2 y a
este le va a tocar la mitad de este
ángulo que se va a dividir entre 2 que
por cierto era el jr
por lo tanto podemos decir que cualquier
valor que tome entre 45 y 55 grados x va
a ser igual a entre 2 x va a ser la
mitad de ese ángulo por lo tanto ya
tenemos un buen de posibles respuestas
para valores de x y bueno esto es todo
por este vídeo por mi parte me voy a
hacer un poco de ejercicio y nos vemos
en el siguiente vídeo